said there are four natural forms for
the octillery Anglin this is the first
one okay so usually we think of in terms
of which of the ratios is first okay so
if I've got you can make this little
subheading natural forms what do you do
you've got sign first okay so sign is
first we'll put sign as the natural kind
of form okay and then because I've got a
plus here and times positive I'm gonna
have that alpha again is satis first but
we change this to a negative sign in
there you're still gonna get the same
amplitude right but you're gonna have X
minus alpha instead okay and if you want
to verify that this checks out you
simply do this step again okay you do
the expansion and you can see because
the sign a plus a minus the expansion
lands you in the negative sign of middle
which is exactly what we want okay so
there's the first two for sign if you've
got a cause at the front instead okay
you end up with a cause maybe fear as
well know careful because it's cause
right and the normal cause a plus B
expansion gives you a negative sign in
the middle okay so if I want a positive
sign that's why I'm gonna have a minus
alpha so it closes backwards right and
by the same token if I've got a cos x
minus piece annuls so this should all be
equivalent I understand you can have our
closed X plus alpha okay now why do we
call these the natural forms why are
these the most easiest way to go to for
all of these okay
alpha is going to be a cute okay
okay that's why we like these forms so
you know you get paisan pay for upon
three or something like that
okay however you guys know that any of
these really all of these four are sort
of equivalent to each other if you just
change the shift okay will change the
face right
I can turn sign into cars by moving it
pile to right so therefore you guys are
seen before one of our pesky habits of
dangerous exam question centers is that
they'd like you to squeeze one form into
one that's not natural okay so for
instance instead of sine x + cos x going
to R sine X plus alpha they'll say put
your X R cos x what's happens there okay
or any of the other varieties so how do
you do it there are two ways so let's
start again and do the same example we
want the sine X plus cos x but this time
let's put in two hmm well you pick one
if we've got one two three which one you
wanna do five what a chole okay we've
already done the first one so take
another one three all right so let's
have a look at this one we went into our
cos x minus alpha okay so there are some
shortcuts we can take here but just to
make sure we're not we're doing for
starters I'm just gonna do it from
scratch
okay so all you need to remember is your
expansions for far as a plus B minus bit
so let's do this right hand side okay
hours at the front of anything
everything in the new expand that's its
presence college is cosine
Thanks I know so far so good
okay so now I do my comparison of
coefficient step and because I've got
pluses here things will line up so I'm
going to get R cos alpha being one and
also B so therefore my are just as
before will be root 2 actually you may
have noticed our is always going to be
the same whichever form you pick because
the difference we're doing between these
is just moving it sideways okay were
sliding it back and forth but that
amplitude is always going to remain the
same
okay so if you've got it in your normal
natural form and you've got our it'll be
the same for every form okay let's get
going
these are the same pairings that we got
before right one in one so that led us
to half the beam remember we got before
actually still there painful okay so
therefore I can rewrite sine X plus cos
x and still Samer to half the front but
it's cos x minus product on for now by
the way because we keep forgetting this
I'm sorry because we've done this
already that tells you that this is
equivalent to through to sine X plus
poetry and in a sense we should have
been able to expect that right because
think about this way sighing and cosine
right now let's pick a different sign
increasing the co states for compliments
right so sine of a is cos off on 2 minus
this difference in ponzu which is
exactly the difference you have reading
here okay do from here to here I move
forward piles and you can also do the
same trick you can take advantage of the
same fact if you're going to either of
these okay so now I'm going to show you
this short form for you know I'm still
going to show you the long form and the
short form for option two okay because
it lends you it leads you to a non acute
angle alright so let's have a go
Neven soon if they want an X minus alpha
what difference would that be okay now
just in here I'm gonna jam in the
expansion to draw out something
important okay so you've got your are at
the front and it's the same expansion as
before but there's a minus sign okay so
okay now when you do your comparison of
coefficients you have to be very very
careful because the coefficient of our
cos alpha
still 1 okay so cos alpha still 1 but he
are this one here outside at the further
cos x is not equal to 1
thank you see that in fact it should be
minus R sine alpha
that's what's equal to work so another
way of saying it is when I've divided
through by R which is returned okay
I'm gonna have sine alpha being minus 1
unreachable okay so by a variety of ways
that think about what this implies then
easy way is just to think about your
coordinates cause alphas 100 to sign up
for this - wanna meet you
cos is positive sine is negative so
where am i I'm in the fourth quadrant
right that's what causes positive and
everything else negative okay
so therefore the angle I'm expecting is
going to be not just a juice but it's
actually a reflex angle right what will
the reflex a will be it's still the
basin was still planned for but in this
quadrant if that's plan for there I do
it all the way around and that angle is
7.4 right
this arm in this quadrant I'm doing 2 pi
minus whatever my basing who is came to
my second plan for so therefore whenever
we write this I'll do it under here
because they're all the same
now when I put it in terms of X minus
alpha you're getting seven PI over four
sums no longer acute not even obtuse
can you see we should have expected this
from the previous line all right what's
the relationship what's the identity
that joins these two lines the other can
you see the difference between these two
is two pi right and the reason why to
pay is significant is because two pi is
the period of sign right so in other
words sign a our backwards didn't know
is sine of a minus two smile or a plus
two pi in your life you can go either
directly gonna get the same result
okay so therefore without doing any of
this comparison of coefficients in that
qartheen can you tell me what if I
wanted cos x plus alpha what would the
alpha beta because cosine is the same
period as sine right so it's going to be
root two cars
X plus y same logic as before I'm going
to take the platform and I'm going to go
forward the period to make this positive
okay so if I add two part of this you're
going to get the same seven platform
right so you've got a couple of
approaches right number one when they
give you this sum this wrong form okay
you can go through first principles and
then you can notice this is negative so
you're in this quadrant and so on and so
forth okay alternatively you can just
work out what's the most natural form
okay you're like well this is what your
given me so did most of it and actually
it means toward this okay
and then you think about which one they
want and then you translate it as
necessary